ITS TIME TO PLAY WORD FROM YOUR MOTHER.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THANKS TO AUTO CORRECT, MOTHERS
AND TEXT MESSAGING IS A VERY
DANGEROUS/HILARIOUS COMBINATION.
COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
GUYS SOME PRICKLY AUTO CORRECTED
TEXTS MOMS SENT THEIR KIDS
AND FOR 250 POINTS, YOU RING
IN WITH A REPLY.
LET'S BEGIN.
"YOUR FATHER BURNT HIS
PENIS IN THE MICROWAVE.
BURNT PENIS."
WHY IS IT CAPITALIZED?
(LAUGHTER)
SEAN.
>> AH, MAN, ARE WE HAVING DAD'S
DICK FOR DINNER AGAIN?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT, LET'S
SEE THE ACTUAL TEXT.
"EW, MOM, WHAT'S THAT SMELL?
YOUR FATHER BURNT HIS PENIS
IN THE MICROWAVE.
BURNT PENIS.
WHAT THE HECK?
BURNT P-CORN.
P-CORN, YOU MEAN POPCORN?
YES, P-CORN."
POINTS TO SEAN O'CONNOR.
>> MOM, I KNOW DAD COOKS
TOO FAST, BUT PLEASE STOP
CALLING YOUR VAGINA
"THE MICROWAVE."
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT ONE, "EMOTIONAL AND VERY
HORNY.
BY THE WAY, HOW ARE YOUR
SHOULDERS AND BACK FEELING.
JUST ASKING?"
ANNIE.
>> A LOT WORSE SINCE YOU
TOLD ME THIS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: LET'S SEE WHAT THE
ACTUAL TEXT SAID.
"I AM LITERALLY GOING TO KILL
MYSELF AFTER READING THAT."
THE MOM IS LIKE "DON'T BE
CRAZY NOW, DON'T BE CRAZY.
MOMMY WAS JUST BEING A
LITTLE EMOTIONAL AND HORNY
FOR A MINUTE."
>> I FEEL LIKE ALL OF OUR
MOMS FEEL LIKE THAT AFTER
THEY READ "50 SHADES OF GRAY".
>> Chris: THAT'S WHAT IT WAS.
THAT IS TOTALLY WHAT IT WAS.
I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT,
ANNIE.
>> NO ONE IS PAYING ATTENTION
TO THE PERSON SAYING THAT
THEY LITERALLY WERE GOING TO
KILL THEMSELVES AND THEN ARE
DYING.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT.
NEXT ONE, "DICK IS COMING IN
MY VULVA.
DICK IS COMING IN MY VULVA,
DICK IS COMING IN MY VULVA
AT 7:00."
YES, ANNIE.
>> STOP NAMING YOUR SEX TOYS
AFTER MY UNCLE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: LET'S SEE WHAT THE
ACTUAL ANSWER WAS.
"VOLVO, MOM?
YES, VULVA!"
(LAUGHTER)
>> IT'S THE SAFEST VAGINA ON
THE MARKET.
>> Chris: IT REALLY IS.
>> I DRIVE A '97 CERVIX.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS FOR THAT ONE,
JULIAN.